welcome to this video playing cool
Romania what is this guy from Namibia um
no maybe I has no GM let's see Gil
popinski Gil popinski but it's not
living in the media right okay d 46 so
let's see what we get is this very often
transpositional so yeah probably an Enzo
I've played this guy three times lost
lost quite a number of games two losses
and one draw yeah this is somehow
transposing into a into Erik goes in now
which I'm not very familiar with to be
totally honest I wonder if he takes you
five okay i can certainly cancel first I
am he has a quick rook c8 maybe rooked
you one if it takes on d 494 bishops III
bc 3 should be okay from yep I've got
the bishop pair and some activity as
compensation for the compromised pawn
structure I am ok moving this out of the
out of the way on d 8 & a 3 is looking
kinda stupid
okay he is also intending now to take
and take on c3 if i take here whoop c5
and night if i was introduced it looks
really decent for black young 94 is
especially annoying yeah it feels like I
played this far too yeah I know how to
call it too simplistic or something it
really feels like black is in good shape
I mean this is certainly not troubling
him much but I have to play a move at
some point at least now night xe5 is
answered by Bishop f6 so probably rook
checks and then I thought 90 form just
to centralize and maybe take only six
sometime you can win a pawn on c3 bit I
mean it's difficult to not lose the part
anyway there's also always bishops III
bc 3 94 m to pick up the porn that way
okay
maybe I have Bishop takes c3 night be
three actually yeah but he can play
Bishop no we cannot night be three now
is displayable
why not isn't this just a far-gone and
green eight-oh or what no Queen each
united to add ok to sorry wow this is
this is already in the morning after sir
I have to find an excuse for ideas like
he takes a two yes so he's going there
utilizing this pin but still if I play
Queen takes you four for example it's
the simple I mean I day for Roxy to is
not not helping Queenie form Queenie
form rook takes III that looks really
shaky that looks really shaky from black
queen for Quint xb3 also look so you're
shaking but I don't see a refutation
queen bee three how weird is that okay
come on let's let's do this now I have
to play move sometime and falling asleep
here so what does this move now Queen
takes be three or up takes you three
Luke takes you three i mean i can't play
any Queen move without being worse I
just I just don't know where exactly I
should go maybe maybe Queen f4 actually
for Bishop e7 like Queen f4 rooks III
Queen f4 look somewhere Bishop e7 using
the pin and attacking the rook and queen
takes b3 quinta xp3 I have various
Desperados I can know I can play Queen B
1 trapping the Queen where took me ages
to see that
I can just play Queen to be one covering
be too and young and here Queen f4 is
the move I guess I'm really finding the
step-by-step young or somewhere else
actually here let's sync for moon Roxy
to bed my bishop is hanging that's a
problem I can also play 90 form yeah I
have to have to move here 1 minute 13 if
he goes to C 2 s also Bishop d3 Bishop
d3 rugby to Bishop e7 I just win some
material i think and other look moves I
mean just Bishop e7 there should be
seven now right or is there drawback how
is he not losing material then
yeah wins the exchange at least if he
goes a five now g5 I take Queen takes
before that's a weird game really weird
stuff but maybe it was working after 18
minutes after 18 moose went down to one
minute both oh wow black resign I'm
really curious if this was any correct
or something I mean it was like
stumbling into stuff so I mean here I
thought he can just play Bishop c3 and
and it's okay that's interesting a
computer actually does not mind my
position I was thinking that I could
have some compensation if he takes it
like here and computer gives equal yeah
maybe yeah there's some ideas like night
b5 maybe this hangs and the dark squared
Bishop is potentially quite strong em
also have this idea hmm computer says
equal interesting it wants to wants to
do this which is actually winning the
exchange the Queen has to protect and
then something like this very computer
is stuff with equal okay but let's have
a look here queen bee three is the best
move and now it wants to play rook c3
and this loosest you to Queenie fried
really induce the same that that's nice
and I was right yeah queen bee three
queen bee oneness the P mafia that's
very important I took me of how to see
that yeah it's actually a funny kind
funny case of a queen trap here it took
me a long time but finally I saw that
the Queen has no squares IAM really nice
so he went with this and now I went here
okay and it is winning a wide winds rook
takes me three is the best saving a
little bit of material and after this I
was thinking looxcie to Bishop d3 but I
compounds the player ah I was I was
intending this this move actually to get
something comparable to the game which
also is winning in exchange it seems the
compo ever gives this as even stronger
that's a difficult for a human I think
because I'm at least in blitz them this
hangs and if he moves it somewhere I go
here and then we have this discovered
attack on the Queen it's very nice okay
you went here and I went with this
computer points out this move as even
stronger yeah well if someone is playing
this against you instead of Bishop e7
you know that they're cheating the idea
here is now Bishop to b5 which seems to
be very strong hmm I don't get it if you
do this let's say how is it winning III
and before yes Wow something like this
yeah amazing yeah but this was the the
human move at least it was my movie and
and he really has no movie I can do this
to continue the game but then I will
take and I was thinking nightie for
should be good here just putting this in
the middle of the board and maybe we
should be far it's really just an
exchange and I have control over the
position so it should win now black has
no decent counterplay that was funny
really funny game yeah I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching